Alex spoke Russian, lived in Russia for a year, worked with Russian refugees in Chicago for two years. And his Russian teacher thought that he only needed one thing to make his life complete.
亚历克斯说俄语，在俄罗斯住过一年，在芝加哥为俄罗斯难民工作了两年。他的俄语老师认为，他的人生若要圆满，只需要一样东西。
She thought I needed a Russian girlfriend. She thought that only Russians would be able to stand up to me the way that I needed to be stood up to, or something. I don't know.
她认为我需要一个俄罗斯女朋友。她觉得只有俄罗斯女性才能像我需要的那样对我严加管教，或者类似的意思。我也不清楚。
Our American women are just too soft.
我们美国的女人太软弱了。
I don't know what you-- I truly don't know. But anyway, that's the thought she had.
我不知道你——我真不知道。但无论如何，这就是她的想法。
So she kept trying to fix him up with Russian women. And this one night, she had him come out with a whole bunch of people, including this woman Elena, who was going to be his date.
于是，她不断尝试给他介绍俄罗斯女朋友。有一天晚上，她让他去参加一个聚会，还带上了那天作为他舞伴的一位名叫埃琳娜的女士。
And so I meet them for dinner. And we're at the sushi restaurant, and we're all eating, and everybody's telling stories, funny stories. And I'm sitting across from my date. And my Russian teacher is turning to me and saying, you know, tell them this story! Tell them that story! And so then I tell them this story and that story, and everybody's laughing, except for my date.
于是我和她们在晚餐时见了面。我们在一家寿司店，大家都在吃饭，每个人都在讲故事，有趣的故事。我坐在舞伴对面。我的俄语老师转向我说，你知道的，给他们讲讲那个故事！讲讲这个故事！于是我就给他们讲了这个那个故事，大家都笑了起来，除了我的舞伴。
And so we leave the sushi restaurant and we go to this club. And we're all dancing. Like, my Russian teacher's dancing, and all of her friends are dancing, and everybody's sort of like, you know, exchanging partners, and it's sort of this fun scene. And everybody's dancing except for my date, who's just sitting at the table and sort of nursing a drink.
后来我们离开了寿司店去了一家俱乐部。我们都在跳舞。我的俄语老师在跳，她的所有朋友也在跳，每个人似乎都在交换舞伴，场面很欢乐。每个人都在跳舞，除了我的舞伴，她只是坐在桌边喝着饮料。
And looking--?
看起来——？
And looking bored. Really bored.
看起来很无聊。真的很无聊。
And so, you know, I keep on coming back from the dance floor, and saying, are you sure you don't want to dance? You want to dance? And then she will sort of smile bitterly, and just shake her head, and-- and so then somebody else will drag me out.
所以，你知道，我不断地从舞池回来，问她，你确定不想跳舞吗？你想跳舞吗？然后她会露出一种苦笑，只是摇摇头，于是别人又会把我拉走。
So finally I come back and I sit down, and I'm sitting next to her, and I'm trying to strike up a conversation. And you know, something about like, I guess you don't like dancing, or something like that. And she sort of looks out at the floor, and there's people having a great time all around. And she sort of like nods her chin towards the floor and she's like, "This is an American dance number."
最后我回到座位坐下，坐在她旁边，试着和她搭话。我说了一些话，大概是说，我想你不喜欢跳舞，或者类似的话。她望向舞池，周围的人都玩得很开心。她微微向舞池点了点下巴说：“这是一种美式舞蹈。”
And I drove away thinking, well, that was a horrible date. Like, neither of us enjoyed each other. And that was a disaster, pretty much. Like, we were not going to be seeing each other again.
我开车离开时心想，那真是一场糟糕的约会。我们谁也没享受对方带来的快乐。那简直是一场灾难。我们以后肯定不会再见面了。
I get to Russian class the next week, and my Russian teacher says, "hey, so are you going to call Elena? She said she had a great time." And I was like, I was floored by that. I was trying to figure out what that could possibly have meant, right?
下周我去上俄语课时，我的俄语老师说：“嘿，你打算给埃琳娜打电话吗？她说她玩得很开心。”我当时完全被惊呆了。我试图弄明白这到底意味着什么，对吧？
And so I was like sort of mulling it over in my head, because it was really fascinating to me. And I realized that I have a very sort of like clear and perhaps culturally informed idea of what a great date is. And it has to do with the idea of, like, what it means to fall in love. And I realized that in my head, what I think about as a great date is what sort of you see in the movies. Like sort of the "falling in love" montage of the movies.
于是我一直在脑海里琢磨这件事，因为它对我来说太令人着迷了。我意识到，我对“伟大的约会”有着非常清晰且可能带有文化色彩的定义。它与所谓的“坠入爱河”的含义有关。我意识到，在我心里，伟大的约会就是你在电影里看到的那种，就像电影中“坠入爱河”的蒙太奇片段。
You know, you go on a great date. It often involves a boardwalk. There's a great deal of sort of like, throwing your heads back in laughter. You might chase each other around a tree.
你知道，你去进行一次很棒的约会。通常会涉及木板路散步。会有很多仰头大笑的场景。你们可能会围着一棵树追逐。
There's the splashing of water.
还有水花的溅起。
Splashing of water is almost always involved.
几乎总是会有水花的溅起。
And I think for her, and this is something that I always noticed when I was in Russia, I think that for her, it's totally different thing. In Russia, and in Russian literature, there's a lot of talk about the soul and soulmates. And I think for her, like, falling in love means finding the one person on the planet who understands the misery of life as deeply and fully as you do. And they can talk to you about it.
我想对于她来说——我在俄罗斯时就注意到了这一点——我认为对于她来说，这是完全不同的事情。在俄罗斯和俄国文学中，有很多关于灵魂和灵魂伴侣的讨论。我想对她而言，坠入爱河意味着找到这个星球上唯一一个能像你一样深刻而全面地理解生活苦难的人。而且他们可以和你交流这些痛苦。
And so when she acted all depressed on their date, she was not actually blowing Alex off like he thought at the time. She was flirting.
所以当她在约会时表现得闷闷不乐时，她其实并不是在拒绝亚历克斯，不像他当时以为的那样。她其实是在调情。
So Alex decides to ask his Russian teacher about this theory, that Americans and Russians have completely different views of what it means to fall in love. And I have to say, he's a little bit nervous to try this out on her, because he's worried that maybe it's insulting or stereotyping Russians. But he explains the theory to her.
于是亚历克斯决定向他的俄语老师请教这个理论：美国人和俄罗斯人对“坠入爱河”的看法截然不同。我不得不说，他对向她验证这个理论感到有些紧张，因为他担心这可能是在侮辱或对俄罗斯人进行刻板印象。但他还是向她解释了这个理论。
And she totally agreed. She was like, that's absolutely right. You're right. And and then she just went on a rant about Americans. And she was like, Americans, they have no understanding of what it's like to fall in love. And like, Americans, I never understand, why do you say, "he makes me laugh?" Why is that so important? "He makes me laugh?" Every American I've ever met, all they say, when you ask them how the relationship is, and they say "he makes me laugh" as if that's the greatest thing in the world? What's so great about "he makes me laugh?"
她完全同意。她说，那绝对是正确的。你是对的。然后她就开始抱怨起美国人来。她说，美国人，他们根本不懂坠入爱河是什么感觉。就像，美国人，我永远不明白，为什么你们总说“他能让我发笑”？为什么那那么重要？“他能让我发笑？”每个我见过的美国人，当你问他们关系如何时，他们只会说“他能让我发笑”，仿佛那是世界上最伟大的事情？“他能让我发笑”到底有什么了不起的？
She just, you know, went off on like, something that I have actually said many times. Like, I just want somebody who makes me laugh.
她的话……你知道的，正好击中了我也曾多次说过的话。就像，我只是想要一个能让我发笑的人。
Some days seems like every story in the world is the story of cultural misunderstanding. Between people of different countries, Muslims and Christians, blacks and whites, Republicans and Democrats, men and women, Spanish speakers and Anglos, adults and children, rich people and poor people. And so today, in this era of misunderstandings abroad and at home, we bring you an hour of stories about what gets lost in translation.
有些日子里，仿佛世界上每一个故事都是关于文化误解的故事。在不同国家的人之间、穆斯林和基督徒之间、黑人和白人之间、共和党人和民主党人之间、男人和女人之间、讲西班牙语的人和讲英语的人之间、成年人和孩子之间、富人和穷人之间。所以今天，在这个无论是在国外还是国内都充满误解的时代，我们为您带来一个小时关于“翻译中丢失的内容”的故事。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in three culture-bridging acts.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为三个桥接文化的故事片段。
Act One, The Chasm Between Comedy and Music. In that act, two brave people step into that chasm. Drop into that chasm. However you put it.
第一幕，喜剧与音乐之间的鸿沟。在这一幕中，两个勇敢的人迈入了那道鸿沟。掉进了那道鸿沟。随便你怎么形容。
Act Two, Star of Bethlehem. We bring you the story of the most important, most respected newsman on television in the town of Bethlehem, who does a program that is unlike any news show that you have ever seen.
第二幕，伯利恒之星。我们为您带来伯利恒镇电视台上最重要、最受尊敬的新闻主播的故事，他做的一档节目与你见过的任何新闻节目都不同。
Act Three. Translating For the Very, Very, Very, Very, Very Tall. In which we have, for a change, on our program a story that gets us close to someone so famous that you may have actually heard of him if you follow pro basketball in the tiniest way. Stay with us.
第三幕，为极其、极其、极其、极其、极其高大的人做翻译。在这一幕中，我们要破例为您讲述一个故事，它让我们接近一位如此出名的人，如果你哪怕稍微关注一下职业篮球，你可能都听说过他的名字。请继续收听。
Act One. The Chasm Between Comedy and Music.
第一幕，喜剧与音乐之间的鸿沟。
Well, we start today's program about translation with a story about karaoke. In karaoke, after all, you are the interpreter. You are the translator. You stand there with the words of the song appearing on a little TV monitor and you try to render a life-size performance-- a translation of the original hit, if you will-- rendered in the musical language of you.
好吧，我们今天关于翻译的节目从一个关于卡拉OK的故事开始。毕竟，在卡拉OK中，你就是诠释者。你就是翻译。你站在那里，歌词出现在小电视显示器上，你试图进行一场真人表演——或者说，一场对原唱热单的翻译——用你自己的音乐语言呈现出来。
And in a way, it's surprising that the only karaoke we have is for music. Why not karaoke of the "I Have a Dream" speech, or the "You talking to me?" from Taxi Driver. Recently Jonathan Goldstein and Starlee Kine, you hear them both on our program from time to time, heard about a karaoke bar which not only had songs, but comedy routines that you could perform onstage. They decided to find out for themselves how stand up comedy translates to the karaoke stage.
从某种程度上讲，令人惊讶的是，我们现有的卡拉OK竟然只有音乐。为什么不能有像《我有一个梦想》演讲，或者《出租车司机》里“你是在跟我说话吗？”那样的卡拉OK呢？最近，乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩——你们偶尔能在我们的节目中听到他们——听说了一家卡拉OK吧，里面不仅有歌，还有你可以上台表演的喜剧段子。他们决定亲自去看看脱口秀是如何转化为卡拉OK舞台表演的。
Starlee and I talk quite a bit about chops. Comedic chops. Pacing, placement of the zinger. When to employ whimsy and when to employ wit. Chops.
我和斯塔莉经常谈论“功力”（chops）。喜剧功力。节奏、抖包袱的时机。何时运用奇思妙想，何时运用机智。功力。
Back when we worked in adjoining cubicles, we'd kill time by arguing over what was funny and what wasn't. Blowing cigar smoke in a baby's face? Not funny. A baby smoking a cigar? Funny.
以前当我们还在相邻的隔间工作时，我们常通过争论什么是好笑的、什么不是来消磨时间。朝婴儿脸上吐雪茄烟？不好笑。婴儿抽雪茄？好笑。
We were like Borscht Belt comedians without the borscht, the belt, or the audience. But the fact that we weren't knocking them dead at Grossinger's every night didn't keep us from coming up with titles for our showbiz bios. Starlee's book was going to be called The Woman Behind the Chops, while I intended to call mine Sir Chops-a-Lot.
我们就像没有罗宋汤、没有腰带、也没有观众的“博尔什地带”喜剧演员。但即使我们没能每天晚上在格罗辛格度假村让观众笑破肚皮，也没能阻止我们为自己的演艺履历想出头衔。斯塔莉的书打算叫《功力背后的女人》，而我打算把我的叫《功力爵士》。
Why, just the other day, I was giving young Starlee a quiz. What's the most important thing in comedy? I asked her.
就在前几天，我还在给年轻的斯塔莉出题。在喜剧中最重要的是什么？我问她。
I have to say--
我不得不说——
Timing.
时机。
Chops.
功力。
So finally, Starlee and I, after years of talking about comedy, actually decided to go out and create comedy. We were going to take it to the stage and tell jokes for an audience at this karaoke bar. We were going to exchange the tweed vestments of the armchair humorologist for the rainbow-striped suspenders of the practitioner. We wanted to see if we had what it took.
所以最后，在谈论了多年喜剧之后，斯塔莉和我终于决定去创作喜剧。我们要把它搬上舞台，为卡拉OK吧的观众讲笑话。我们要把扶手椅幽默家的花呢背心换成从业者的彩虹条纹背带。我们想看看自己是否具备那样的能力。
The karaoke bar is called The Hidden Cove, and it had catalogs of different comedy routines, all from the late '80s, early '90s. Starlee had already looked through them. She decided she was going to do a man-bashing routine called "Men are Perfect-- Jerks." We talked about the proper delivery.
这家卡拉OK吧叫“隐藏的海湾”，里面有各种喜剧段子的目录，全都是80年代末、90年代初的。斯塔莉已经浏览过了。她决定做一个名为“男人是完美的——混蛋”的抨击男人的段子。我们讨论了适当的演绎方式。
Men are perfect. Jerks. How was that?
男人是完美的。混蛋。觉得怎么样？
Too deadpan. Like, imagine yourself walking away from the mike and then coming back to the mike, turning your head and saying into the microphone, "Jerks!"
太面瘫了。想象一下你从麦克风旁走开，然后又走回来，转过头对着麦克风说：“混蛋！”
OK. Men are perfect-- jerks!
好吧。男人是完美的——混蛋！
That's not bad. I'd give it maybe a little bit more pause.
还不赖。我会觉得再多一点停顿会更好。
The difference in our comedic approach is vast, as is our approach to life. At the office where Starlee and I used to work together, people whose names she didn't even know would seek her out, bringing her homemade bread, presenting her with souvenirs from their vacations, and even setting aside her favorite caramel taffies from the communal office candy dish. I, on the other hand, had made the effort to learn the names of their children, grandchildren, and in one case, their pet hamster, Mr. Jinglepot. For all of this, I got nothing.
我们在喜剧方法上的差异巨大，对待生活的态度也一样。在我们过去一起工作的办公室里，她甚至连名字都不知道的人都会去找她，给她送自制面包，送她度假纪念品，甚至把公共糖果盘里她最喜欢的焦糖太妃糖留给她。而我，哪怕努力记住了他们孩子、孙子，甚至是在其中一个案例里连他们宠物仓鼠“叮当罐先生”的名字都记住了，却什么都没得到。
Starlee had concerns about the caliber of the jokes on the karaoke machine at the bar, how stale they might be. I explained to her that the material, no matter how cliched or boorish, did not matter. A true humorist, I said, could stand on stage and get laughs while reading an eviction notice. It was all in the delivery. It was all about chops.
斯塔莉担心卡拉OK机里那些笑话的质量，担心它们可能太陈旧。我向她解释说，内容无论多么陈词滥调或粗鲁都不重要。我说，一个真正的幽默家可以站在舞台上，通过读一张驱逐通知单让观众发笑。关键在于演绎。一切都在于“功力”。
When we showed up, we learned that The Hidden Cove is a very popular and beloved karaoke bar and it was filled with patrons who came there every week to sing. This was the first week of the Iraq war, and the regulars, just like everyone else, had wanted some diversion, a night away from the news. They took their karaoke very seriously, too. One man was hunched over a tattered notebook that he brought from home in which he had neatly penciled the code numbers of his favorite karaoke songs, row after row of them.
当我们到达时，得知“隐藏的海湾”是一家非常受欢迎且深受喜爱的卡拉OK吧，里面挤满了每周都来唱歌的常客。这是伊拉克战争的第一周，常客们和其他所有人一样，想要一些消遣，一个远离新闻的夜晚。他们对卡拉OK也极其认真。有一个人埋头于他从家里带来的破旧笔记本，上面整整齐齐地用铅笔写着他最喜欢的卡拉OK歌曲的代码编号，一行又一行。
As people got on the stage to sing and dance, there was a general feeling of warmth and beery encouragement in the air. Everyone seemed to know everyone else. And when we asked them about the comedy routines on the karaoke machine, no one could recall ever having seen them done. Even the owners of the bar weren't quite sure what we were talking about.
当人们上台唱歌跳舞时，空气中洋溢着一种热情和酒精带来的鼓励。每个人似乎都认识彼此。当我们问起卡拉OK机上的喜剧段子时，没人记得见过有人表演过。就连酒吧老板也不太清楚我们在说什么。
We finally found a lone page of comedy karaoke material and we signed up to go on. I was after a woman singing a karaoke classic.
我们终于找到了一页孤零零的喜剧卡拉OK资料，并报了名。我排在一位唱卡拉OK经典歌曲的女士后面。
One of these days these boots are gonna walk all over you!
总有一天，这些靴子会把你踩在脚下！
My routine was called "My Parents Hated Me." My strategy was to deadpan my way through, following each punchline with my patented hapless look.
我的段子叫“我的父母讨厌我”。我的策略是全程保持面瘫，每个笑点之后都带上我招牌式的倒霉表情。
I tell you. I had one hell of a childhood. I'm not saying my parents didn't love me, but my bath toys were a radio and a toaster.
我告诉你们。我的童年真是糟透了。我不是说父母不爱我，但我的洗澡玩具只是一个收音机和一个烤面包机。
Nothing. Complete joyless silence.
什么反应都没有。完全是毫无欢乐的死寂。
Some things just don't translate to the karaoke stage. A karaoke machine, for instance, has no instinct for comedic timing. It just keeps scrolling down at the same pace. This means that sometimes you have to wait for a punchline to a joke for several awkward moments after having delivered the setup. It was messing up my chops.
有些东西就是无法转化到卡拉OK舞台上。例如，卡拉OK机对喜剧时机毫无直觉。它只是以恒定的速度向下滚动。这意味着有时候你在说完铺垫后，必须等待好几秒尴尬的时刻才能等到笑点。这完全破坏了我的“功力”。
When I got lost, a cop helped me to look for my parents. "Do you think we'll ever find them?" I cried. The cop said, "I don't know. There are so many places they could hide."
当我走丢时，一个警察帮我找父母。“你觉得我们能找到他们吗？”我哭着问。警察说：“我不知道。他们可以藏的地方太多了。”
As I walked off the stage, no one in the audience would meet my gaze. Still, given the circumstances, I didn't think I had done that bad. Next up was Starlee.
当我走下舞台时，观众席里没人敢看我的眼睛。不过，考虑到当时的情况，我觉得自己表现得还没那么差。接下来是斯塔莉。
Hey, how about a little male-bashing?
嘿，来点抨击男人的段子怎么样？
[AUDIENCE ENCOURAGEMENT]
[观众鼓励]
Starlee pulls out all these moves. She shrugs her shoulders as if to say, what can you do? She breaks free of the staccato rhythms of the karaoke screen and makes the material her own. She even does this thing where she points your toes inward to make herself look littler, and thus cuter. She was like a pigeon-toed puppy taking its very first steps.
斯塔莉使出了浑身解数。她耸耸肩，仿佛在说，你能怎么办呢？她打破了卡拉OK屏幕上那种断断续续的节奏，赋予了内容自己的特色。她甚至做了一个把脚尖向内扣的动作，让自己看起来更小一点，从而显得更可爱。她就像一只内八字脚的小狗迈出了第一步。
Where's the best place to hide money from a man? Your forehead.
藏私房钱的最好地方是哪里？你的额头。
She was winning over the crowd and getting laughs. My laughs. They took to her in the same way people in the office did.
她赢得了观众，也赢得了笑声。我的那些笑声。他们像办公室里的人那样喜欢她。
Thank you!
谢谢！
I decided to head back up on stage. I was warmed up and the audience was a little more familiar with my work. Plus, I chose a better routine this time. Earlier I had self-deprecated myself out of laughs. Now, armed with a new selection of material from the karaoke machine, celebrity-bashing jokes from 1992.
我决定再次回到舞台。我热身完毕，观众也对我更熟悉了一些。而且，这次我选了一个更好的段子。之前我通过自嘲把笑声都赶跑了。现在，带着卡拉OK机里的新素材——1992年的抨击名人笑话。
I hear Cher named her daughter Chastity in memory of her preschool years.
我听说雪儿给女儿取名“贞洁”，是为了纪念她学龄前的岁月。
Not only were these jokes old and dated, but they were also tasteless and offensive.
这些笑话不仅陈旧过时，而且毫无品味，甚至令人反感。
Did you hear about Roseanne Arnold's new soap opera?
你听说罗珊·阿诺德的新肥皂剧了吗？
Still, I soldiered on, unaware that the grandest failure of timing in the history of comedy was about to unfold.
尽管如此，我还是硬着头皮继续，根本不知道喜剧史上最伟大的时机惨败即将上演。
Before I play you this next bit of tape, I should say, in my own defense, that a karaoke screen holds a weird, hypnotic power. You can't help reading whatever rolls down the screen, and you only figure out the meaning of the words you speak as they are tumbling out of your mouth. And then it's too late.
在播放下一段录音之前，我必须为自己辩解一下，卡拉OK屏幕有一种奇怪的催眠力量。你会忍不住去读屏幕上滚动的任何东西，直到字句从嘴里冒出来时，你才意识到它们的意思。但那时已经太迟了。
I'm going to play you the tape now. Please remember, it's not my fault. Don't judge me.
我现在播放那段录音。请记住，这不是我的错。不要评判我。
What's the difference between Ted Kennedy and the Iraqi army? Ted Kennedy has at least one confirmed kill.
泰德·肯尼迪和伊拉克军队有什么区别？泰德·肯尼迪至少有一个确切的击杀记录。
[BOOING]
[嘘声四起]
I don't write this stuff!
这些段子不是我写的！
[INCREASED BOOING]
[嘘声更响了]
Let me just reiterate. This was during the first week of the Iraq war, and things were not going as easily as America had hoped. American soldiers were dying, and there was no end in sight. A few days earlier or a few days later and my words would not have stung in the same way.
让我再重申一遍。这是在伊拉克战争的第一周，情况并不像美国希望的那样顺利。美国士兵在牺牲，战争看不到尽头。如果早几天或晚几天讲，我的话就不会有那种刺痛感。
It was not even clear what the audience was booing. It was like they just didn't know what else to do. Perhaps they were booing the sheer extraordinary coincidence at all. Here was this leftover joke from the first Gulf War being told for the first time in over a decade, and being told the very week we had gone back to war with the same country. It was like I just delivered a punchline after a ten year pause.
甚至不清楚观众是在嘘什么。就好像他们只是不知道还能做什么。也许他们是在嘘这种极其不可思议的巧合本身。这是一个被遗忘了十年的第一次海湾战争时期的过时笑话，却在我们与同一个国家再次开战的那一周被讲了出来。就好像我在停顿十年后才讲出了一个笑点。
Stupidly, I still somehow believed I could redeem myself. Instead, what rolled down the screen next was the second most tasteless joke from 1992.
愚蠢的是，我仍然天真地相信自己能挽回局面。相反，屏幕上接下来滚出的，是1992年第二无聊的笑话。
What's Mike Tyson's definition of foreplay? Jesus, that's--
迈克·泰森对前戏的定义是什么？天啊，这……
[BOOING]
[嘘声四起]
At this point, the owner actually turned off my mike.
此时，老板直接关掉了我的麦克风。
Thank you!
谢谢！
I've always held the greatest gift an entertainer can receive to be laughter that turns into applause. You know, that moment where a wave of laughter climaxes and breaks apart into the kind of appreciative clapping that says to a performer, we can no longer laugh because our sides are hurting with the pain that is too great, so now we will switch to clapping. God bless you, funny wise man.
我一直认为艺人能收到的最伟大的礼物就是由笑声转化而来的掌声。你知道，那种笑声浪潮达到顶峰，然后破碎成感激的掌声的时刻，那告诉表演者，我们已经笑不动了，因为我们侧腹痛得厉害，那种痛苦太强烈了，所以现在我们要改用鼓掌的方式。上帝保佑你，有趣的智者。
Now, instead of laughter turning into applause, I was experiencing boos turning into applause as I slunk off the stage.
现在，我并没有体验到由笑声转化的掌声，而是当我灰溜溜地走下舞台时，听着嘘声转变成了掌声。
There wasn't an aspect of that applause that was sort of-- that they were kind of with me, that they were sort of, hey, you're all right? Like we both just went through a bad situation--
那样的掌声里根本没有一点点——那种他们站在我这边、那种“嘿，你没事的？”的感觉，就像我们两个刚经历了一场糟糕的情况——
Are you kidding?
你在开玩笑吗？
A little. I mean, because a little, I have to admit that a little bit, I kind of felt like there was sort of sympathetic applause. A little bit.
有点吧。我是说，我必须承认，有那么一瞬间，我确实觉得那有点像同情的掌声。稍微有一点。
Oh, you're crazy. You're so crazy. I can't believe it.  You're in total denial.
哦，你疯了。你真的疯了。我不敢相信。你完全是在自我否认。
No, I mean, I just wanted to run that by you. Because I thought maybe that was possible.
不，我是说，我只是想向你核实一下。因为我觉得那可能是有可能的。
No. Trust me. They were against you.
不。相信我。他们是在反抗你。
So I think what this whole experience has taught us is that certain things just don't translate.
所以我认为，整个经历教会我们的是，有些东西就是无法转化。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I mean, karaoke is best served for music. I think that's the lesson that we've both learned from this experience. That it's better to stick to, you know, songs and music, like "These Boots are Made for Walking," and leave comedy off the karaoke stage.
是啊。我是说，卡拉OK还是留给音乐吧。我想这就是我们从这次经历中学到的教训。最好坚持唱，你知道的，像《这些靴子是为行走而生》这样的歌，把喜剧从卡拉OK舞台上撤下来。
I would have to say, I disagree.
我不得不说，我不同意。
Oh, do you?
哦，是吗？
Comedy translated just fine when I went up.
我上台的时候，喜剧转化得很好啊。
Since karaoke night, I was so pumped up from my success--
从卡拉OK之夜开始，我因为成功而感到如此兴奋——
Oh really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah. That I thought up some new titles for my book. Do you want to hear them?
是啊。我为我的书想了一些新标题。想听听吗？
Uh, sure.
呃，当然。
OK. My Chops, My Life. Chopzilla, The Chop That Was Heard Around the World, Queen Choptifa--
好的。《我的功力，我的人生》、《功力斯拉》、《那声惊天动地的功力》、《女王功力法》——
Is this your idea of a victory lap?
这就是你所谓的胜利巡游吗？
I'm funnier than Jonathan.
我比乔纳森幽默多了。
That's nice.
那真不错。
The Kid Stays In the Chop, A Chip Off the Old Chopping Block, Li'l Chop, It's Lonely Near the Chop, They Call Me Choppy--
《孩子留在了功力里》、《老功力块上掉下来的一块筹码》、《小功力》、《功力边缘很寂寞》、《他们叫我功力小子》——
Jonathan Goldstein with Starlee Kine. Or is that the other way around?
乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩。或者是反过来？
Act Two. Star of Bethlehem.
第二幕，伯利恒之星。
OK, now these possibly helpful geopolitical facts. Most Palestinians don't speak Hebrew. Most Israelis don't speak Arabic. Where Palestinians live, in a place like Bethlehem on the West Bank, Israeli newspapers aren't even for sale. Checkpoints block the passage of civilians from one side to another. All of this to say, each side has very little daily knowledge what the other side is thinking and talking about.
好了，现在说一些可能有帮助的地缘政治事实。大多数巴勒斯坦人不懂希伯来语。大多数以色列人不懂阿拉伯语。在巴勒斯坦人居住的地方，比如约旦河西岸的伯利恒，以色列报纸甚至都没得卖。检查站阻挡了平民从一边到另一边的通行。所有这些都说明，双方每天对彼此在想什么、在谈论什么几乎一无所知。
But for the last three and a half years, since the beginning of the current intifada, a Palestinian journalist in Bethlehem had a nightly news program on Bethlehem TV where he translates the Israeli nightly news broadcasts into Arabic, live, in real time. He also translates and summarizes articles from the Israeli newspapers and internet sites. The show is popular in Bethlehem, but it is very complicated speaking your enemy's language. Nancy Updike tells the story.
但过去三年半里，自当前起义爆发以来，伯利恒的一位巴勒斯坦记者在“伯利恒电视台”有一个夜间新闻节目，他会在现场实时将以色列的夜间新闻广播翻译成阿拉伯语。他还翻译和总结以色列报纸和网站上的文章。这个节目在伯利恒很受欢迎，但讲述敌人的语言是非常复杂的。南希·厄普代克讲述了这个故事。
Because he's translating, Nasser Laham is reporting things that have never been reported in the territories before. Things that in the normal course of events are not even talked about in public.
因为他是翻译，纳赛尔·拉汉正在报道以前在巴勒斯坦领土上从未报道过的事情。那些在正常情况下甚至不会在公开场合谈论的事情。
When Yasser Arafat slapped the former head of security for the West Bank, stuck a gun in his face, and said, "I'm going to kill you," Nasser's translation of an Israeli TV report was the only Arabic language broadcast to mention the incident. When an Israeli newspaper published an expose about corruption in the top leadership in Bethlehem, Nasser was the only one who picked the story up, and he broadcast his translation in spite of a flurry of increasingly threatening phone calls from the leaders involved. Soon after, they were all ousted.
当亚西尔·阿拉法特扇了约旦河西岸前安全负责人的耳光，把枪抵在他的脸上说“我要杀了你”时，纳赛尔对以色列电视报道的翻译是唯一提及此事的阿拉伯语广播。当一家以色列报纸刊登了一篇关于伯利恒高层领导腐败的调查报告时，纳赛尔是唯一报道这则新闻的人，他不顾相关领导打来的一连串日益严重的威胁电话，播出了他的翻译。不久之后，他们全被撤职了。
And even though the story came from a newspaper in Jerusalem, which is only 15 minutes away from Bethlehem, most likely, no one would have heard about it if Nasser hadn't told the story.
尽管这个故事来自耶路撒冷的报纸，距离伯利恒只有15分钟路程，但很可能如果不是纳赛尔讲述这个故事，没人会听说。
There is no comparing between the Palestinian newspapers and the Israeli newspapers. Because our newspapers are, I mean, very bad. It's hard. It's hard to take the truth from your enemies, on the Israeli side. Not from the Palestinian leadership.
巴勒斯坦报纸和以色列报纸之间没有任何可比性。因为我们的报纸，我的意思是，非常糟糕。这很难。很难从你的敌人那里获取真相，从以色列那边。而不是从巴勒斯坦领导层那里。
All Palestinian media-- newspapers, radio, television, except for private television stations like Bethlehem TV-- are tightly controlled by the Palestinian Authority. Take the way the Palestinian papers covered the recent power struggle between Arafat and the new prime minister, known as Abu Mazen, whose appointment was supposed to be the first step toward a new peace process.
所有的巴勒斯坦媒体——报纸、广播、电视，除了像“伯利恒电视台”这样的私营电视台——都受到巴勒斯坦民族权力机构的严格控制。看看巴勒斯坦报纸是如何报道最近阿拉法特和新任总理阿布·马赞之间的权力斗争的，阿布·马赞的任命被认为是通往新和平进程的第一步。
In the period of Abu Mazen government, they didn't include anything about Abu Mazen. They start to search for Saddam Hussein and the SARS.
在阿布·马赞政府期间，他们根本没提关于阿布·马赞的任何事。他们开始搜寻萨达姆·侯赛因和非典病毒。
So they were writing about the SARS virus rather than Abu Mazen?
所以他们写的都是关于非典病毒而不是阿布·马赞？
Of course, yeah.
当然，是啊。
Why weren't they writing about Abu Mazen?
为什么他们不写阿布·马赞？
You know. You know, Nancy. I keep the newspapers in my house for the history. To say it in 20, 21, 22 [UNINTELLIGIBLE] when all the newspapers in the world, they talk about Abu Mazen, the Palestinian newspaper, they didn't do that.
你知道的。你知道的，南希。我把报纸留在我家里作为历史资料。为了在20、21、22年说出来，当世界上所有的报纸都在谈论阿布·马赞时，巴勒斯坦的报纸却没有这样做。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Whenever there's a suicide bombing of any size in Israel, Israeli TV goes into nonstop crisis coverage, and Bethlehem TV carries this live, with Nasser translating for hours. You see emergency workers running stretchers with burned and bloody people to ambulances. I watched with a translator of my own. You'll hear Nasser's voice in Arabic, then my translator in English.
每当以色列发生任何规模的自杀式爆炸袭击时，以色列电视台就会进行不间断的危机报道，“伯利恒电视台”会全程直播，由纳赛尔翻译数小时。你看到救援人员抬着担架，送走被烧焦和流血的人员去救护车。我和我自己的翻译一起看。你会听到纳赛尔的阿拉伯语声音，然后是我翻译的英语。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
You been at the cafeteria, yes?
你是在咖啡馆里吗，是的？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
We were sitting.
我们当时正坐着。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I heard explosion.
我听到了爆炸声。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
And she's talking while she's shivering.
她一边说一边在发抖。
Nasser interjects these kind of details when he's translating-- she's shivering as she's talking-- because he wants his viewers to know exactly what's happening. They can't hear her voice shaking, so he tells them.
纳赛尔在翻译时会加入这些细节——她说话时在发抖——因为他想让他的观众确切地知道发生了什么。他们听不到她颤抖的声音，所以他告诉他们。
If the Israeli knows what's happening in the Palestinian lands with details, and the Palestinian knows what's happening in the Israeli cities with details, trust me. The decisions would be different.
如果以色列人了解巴勒斯坦领土上发生的细节，而巴勒斯坦人也了解以色列城市中发生的细节，相信我，决定会有所不同。
Do you think that watching the coverage of a suicide bombing, do you think it makes Palestinians watching it more sympathetic to Israelis?
你认为观看自杀式爆炸的报道，会让看节目的巴勒斯坦人对以色列人更抱有同情心吗？
No. I think that the question is wrong. Your question is wrong. Why? Because they saw before. Big chance they saw. Anyone can open the Israeli television and saw the pictures. But they didn't understand what they are talking in the television with the Hebrew. This is my work. To translate emotions, facts, numbers.
不。我认为这个问题本身是错的。为什么？因为他们以前看过。很有可能他们看过。任何人都可以打开以色列电视看到画面。但他们听不懂电视里用希伯来语在说些什么。这是我的工作。翻译情感、事实、数字。
In fact, plenty of the details Nasser translates have got to stir outrage rather than sympathy. Nasser's producer told me that one of the reasons Bethlehem TV decided it was important to follow Israel's continuous coverage after a suicide attack is that Israelis speak then without filters. Politicians openly called for what's known as "transfer"-- the removal of all Palestinians from the territories. Ordinary Israelis call for revenge, say the peace process is hopeless because Palestinians are all terrorists.
事实上，纳赛尔翻译的许多细节反而可能会激起愤怒而非同情。纳赛尔的制片人告诉我，伯利恒电视台认为在自杀式袭击后跟随以色列的持续报道很重要，原因之一是以色列人在说话时没有过滤。政客们公开呼吁所谓的“转移”——将所有巴勒斯坦人从领土上清除。普通以色列人呼吁报复，说和平进程毫无希望，因为巴勒斯坦人全是恐怖分子。
Nasser translates it all without hedging. Palestinians never use the words "terrorist" or "suicide bomber." They say "shahid"-- "martyr." But when Israel TV says terrorist, Nasser does too.
纳赛尔毫不隐晦地翻译了所有这些内容。巴勒斯坦人从不使用“恐怖分子”或“自杀式炸弹袭击者”这些词。他们说“沙希德”（shahid）——意为“殉道者”。但当以色列电视说恐怖分子时，纳赛尔也这么说。
I'd wanted to meet Nasser ever since I saw this book he published about Arafat, which is so strange and provocative that it's not in any Palestinian political category so much as orbiting all of them. The cover of the book is red with a picture of Arafat smiling, and the title is The Truth, the Whole Truth About Yasir Arafat, The Man Who's Led Fatah and the PLO for 37 Years. On the back it says, "In this book, I put between the hands of the reader what has never been said before about the man who led one of the greatest and longest liberation movements in the world. With all modesty, I present the reader with information in opposition to what Palestinian, Arabic, Islamic, Western, and Israeli research and study have determined about this man.
从我看到他出版的那本关于阿拉法特的书起，我就一直想见纳赛尔，那本书是如此奇特且具有挑衅性，它不属于任何巴勒斯坦政治类别，而是围绕着所有类别运转。书的封面是红色的，上面印着阿拉法特微笑着的照片，标题是《真相，关于亚西尔·阿拉法特的全部真相，那个领导法塔赫和巴解组织37年的男人》。背面写着：“在这本书里，我向读者展示了从未被说过的关于这个领导了世界上最伟大且最长的解放运动之一的男人的事迹。我非常谦逊地向读者提供与巴勒斯坦、阿拉伯、伊斯兰、西方和以色列研究及学术界对这个人的定论相反的信息。”
When you open the book, it's empty. All the pages are blank, except the very first page, where Nasser invites the readers to fill the book with their own opinions. "I'm confident that you'll have something to write," he says "because every person views President Arafat as he wishes."
当你打开这本书，它是空的。所有页面都是空白的，除了第一页，纳赛尔邀请读者用他们自己的观点填满这本书。“我确信你们会有东西要写，”他说，“因为每个人都按照自己的意愿来看待阿拉法特主席。”
Half the Palestinians I show the book to get really angry. The other half burst out laughing, at least in part due to shock. You just don't see this kind of joke-- an absurdist prank-- in the Territories, where the situation is so dire, where everyone feels like the entire world is against them and their leader.
我展示这本书的一半巴勒斯坦人感到非常愤怒。另一半则大笑起来，这部分是因为震惊。在领土上，你根本看不到这种笑话——一种荒诞的恶作剧——那里局势如此严峻，每个人都觉得全世界都在反对他们和他们的领袖。
In general, Nasser's sense of humor is pretty dark. One time, he was telling me how much the Arab world hates Israel's Prime Minister, Ariel Sharon He offered this prescription for fighting al-Qaeda and achieving world peace.
总的来说，纳赛尔的幽默感相当黑暗。有一次，他告诉我阿拉伯世界有多讨厌以色列总理阿里埃勒·沙龙。他给出了这个打击基地组织并实现世界和平的处方。
If Sharon supported al-Qaeda or Osama bin Laden, maybe all the Middle East will be against al-Qaeda. It's a good idea. Try that.
如果沙龙支持基地组织或奥萨马·本·拉登，也许整个中东都会反对基地组织。这倒是个好主意。试试看吧。
Nasser drives to work in the morning in his beat up '84 Opel hatchback, a car so crappy it's like a giant neon sign saying, I am not on the take. He turns on the TV and Israeli army radio and starts looking at the breaking news in Israel over the internet.
纳赛尔早上开着他那辆破旧的84年欧宝掀背车去上班，这辆车破得就像一个巨大的霓虹灯招牌，写着“我没收钱”。他打开电视和以色列陆军电台，开始查看互联网上以色列的突发新闻。
He lights a cigarette. He smokes all the time and in this way that makes you feel like everyone else who smokes is just messing around. With every drag, he takes all the smoke in in a big gulp. He smokes each one down into the filter is about to melt. I've never seen him eat.
他点燃了一支烟。他一直抽个不停，这种抽法让你觉得其他所有抽烟的人都只是在闹着玩。每一口，他都大口大口地吸入所有的烟。他每一根都抽到过滤嘴快要融化。我从没见过他吃东西。
Nasser taught himself Hebrew in prison from an Arabic Hebrew dictionary he asked his parents to send him. I should mention that so many Palestinian men have been to prison that it's almost a given, especially men around Nasser's age, 36, who were young activists at university during the first intifada.
纳赛尔是在监狱里通过他让父母寄给他的一本阿希字典自学希伯来语的。我应该提一下，这么多巴勒斯坦人都坐过牢，这几乎成了一种常态，尤其是像纳赛尔这个年纪，36岁，在第一次起义期间还是大学里的年轻活动家的人。
As soon as he learned Hebrew, he started teaching other prisoners. He's taught it ever since-- to friends, relatives, students, businessmen. It's sort of a compulsion.
他学会希伯来语后，就开始教其他囚犯。他从此以后一直在教——教朋友、亲戚、学生、商人。这有点像是一种强迫症。
His crusade to teach and translate Hebrew raises a question. What good is it, in a violent conflict that's been going on for decades, to speak your enemy's language? What can it change?
他教授和翻译希伯来语的十字军运动引发了一个问题。在持续了几十年的暴力冲突中，会讲敌人的语言有什么用？它能改变什么？
Nasser reads and enjoys Israeli novels. He listens to Israeli pop, has Israeli friends, mostly journalists. He's an idealist. He believes that learning the language of the other side can be the first step toward understanding them, toward peace.
纳赛尔阅读并欣赏以色列小说。他听以色列流行音乐，有以色列朋友，大多是记者。他是一个理想主义者。他相信学习对方的语言可以成为迈向理解、迈向和平的第一步。
A 28 year old named Mohammed with a big, sad face, a guy Nasser taught Hebrew to, tells me this story about being in an Israeli hospital, in a room full of Israeli kids, when he was 16. Mohammed asked the kid in the bed next to him, in Hebrew, "So what are you in for?" "Car accident," the kid said. "And you?" Mohammed said, "I was shot in the leg by an Israeli soldier."
一个名叫穆罕默德的28岁年轻人，长着一张忧郁的大脸，是纳赛尔教过希伯来语的学生。他告诉我在16岁时在一家以色列医院住在一个满是以色列孩子的房间里的故事。穆罕默德用希伯来语问隔壁床的孩子：“你是因为什么进来的？”“车祸，”那个孩子说。“那你呢？”穆罕默德说，“我被以色列士兵射中了腿。”
They asked me, why they shot you? Are you one of the terrorists? Are you Hamas? Are you jihad? And I said, no. I'm not Hamas. I'm not jihad. I'm a student. I go to my school. It wasn't a war. It was nothing. I mean, six in the morning. There was no clashing. No throwing stone. Nothing, nothing.
他们问我，他们为什么开枪打你？你是恐怖分子吗？你是哈马斯吗？你是圣战组织吗？我说，不。我不是哈马斯。我不是圣战组织。我是一个学生。我要去学校。那不是战争。什么都不是。我的意思是，早上六点。没有冲突。没有扔石头。什么都没有，什么都没有。
And he was, yeah, I feel, like, sorry. We are sorry. I'm sorry. They said. I told him that you don't have to say sorry because you are not the one who shot me. And he was just, [INAUDIBLE]. [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
然后他，是的，我感觉，就像，很抱歉。他们说，我们很抱歉。我告诉他你不必说抱歉，因为射击我的人不是你。然后他只是，[听不清]……[听不清]。
His mother, because she can every day to come to the hospital. My mother, she can't, because there's a checkpoint. But his a mother, she can come every day. And she was bringing food to me, also. [UNINTELLIGIBLE], food, shaving machine.
他的母亲，因为她每天都能来医院。我的母亲，她不能，因为有一个检查站。但他的母亲，她每天都能来。她也给我带了吃的。[听不清]，食物，刮胡刀。
She brought you a razor?
她给你带了把剃须刀？
Yeah. She give me her phone number. If you need anything, just call. We are here. They asked me a lot of times to come to visit. And I hope, when I can.
是啊。她给了我她的电话号码。如果你需要什么，随时打电话。我们在这里。他们好几次邀请我去拜访。我希望，当我能的时候。
Not everyone Nasser taught Hebrew to is so hopeful about it.
并不是每一个纳赛尔教过希伯来语的人都如此充满希望。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Nasser taught this guy in prison. He says speaking Hebrew helps if you want to have a personal conversation with an Israeli, gets to know their life. But when it comes to politics, knowing the language doesn't make any difference at all. The same walls are there, just more clearly.
纳赛尔在监狱里教过这个家伙。他说如果你想和以色列人进行私人谈话、了解他们的生活，讲希伯来语是有帮助的。但当涉及到政治时，懂这种语言根本没有任何区别。同样的墙还在那里，只是更加清晰了。
Still, if your only two choices or violence or talking, Nasser chooses talking. He and Mohammed are part of a group of people who do training for community leaders in nonviolence and what they call "compassionate listening--" how to listen to someone you really, really disagree with. Nasser is against suicide bombings, feels that the Palestinian people have a right to resist, but that the armed resistance is not working at all.
不过，如果你的两个选择只有暴力或交流，纳赛尔选择了交流。他和穆罕默德属于一个为社区领袖进行非暴力培训和所谓“同情聆听”的人群——如何聆听你非常、非常不同意的人。纳赛尔反对自杀式爆炸袭击，觉得巴勒斯坦人民有权反抗，但武装反抗根本不起作用。
Given all this, given his politics, I was surprised by some of the things I saw on Bethlehem TV. One day there were hours of song celebrating martyrs to the Palestinian cause, including suicide bombers. Another time, I saw an unforgettably baroque video celebrating Saddam Hussein.
鉴于这一切，鉴于他的政治倾向，我对比利恒电视台看到的一些内容感到惊讶。有一天，有几个小时的歌曲在庆祝为巴勒斯坦事业献身的“殉道者”，包括自杀式炸弹袭击者。还有一次，我看到了一段令人难忘的巴洛克式视频，庆祝萨达姆·侯赛因。
[SINGING IN ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语演唱]
Picture a plump man in a long, blue tunic smiling, singing, and pumping a machine gun up and down in time to the music. Behind him, a crowd of men in uniform is moving their guns and dancing in time, also. They're holding a large picture of Saddam Hussein in front of them. Then Saddam himself appears onscreen in a fedora, firing a pistol in the air and smiling. Then the Iraqi army is jogging, followed by anti-aircraft guns shooting, and soldiers marching, and tanks moving against the sunset, and mosques, and more of Saddam in the fedora.
想象一下一个穿着长长的蓝色长袍、身材丰满的男人微笑着唱歌，随着音乐节奏上下舞动着一把机关枪。在他身后，一群穿着制服的男人也在随着节奏移动枪支和跳舞。他们面前拿着一张巨大的萨达姆·侯赛因的照片。然后萨达姆本人戴着软呢帽出现在屏幕上，向空中开枪并微笑着。然后伊拉克军队在慢跑，接着是防空炮射击，士兵们行军，坦克移动在日落背景下，还有清真寺，以及更多戴着软呢帽的萨达姆。
This was April. The war in Iraq was long over.
这是四月。伊拉克战争早已结束。
When I ask Nasser about it, he tells me not everything on the program reflects his own political views. People call and request these videos all the time, so he plays them. But then he also broadcasts stuff they don't request.
当我问纳赛尔时，他告诉我并不是节目上的一切都反映了他自己的政治观点。人们一直在打电话点播这些视频，所以他播放它们。但后来他也播出一些他们没点播的东西。
Look, Nancy. Yesterday I translated all the speech about the Holocaust. And the people asking, why? They are our enemy. I said, we have to know also they are suffering. We have know a lot about the Holocaust. They're surprised, but I know that they trust me, because I was in the Israeli prison six years, because I am living in the [SPEAKING ARABIC] camp, refugee camp, because I am a Muslim, because I am poor, not rich-- they trust me. They said, OK. If you say that, we will know a lot about the Holocaust.
看，南希。昨天我翻译了所有关于大屠杀的演讲。人们问，为什么？他们是我们的敌人。我说，我们也必须知道他们也在受苦。我们必须了解很多关于大屠杀的事情。他们很惊讶，但我知道他们信任我，因为我在以色列监狱待过六年，因为我住在[阿拉伯语]难民营，因为我是穆斯林，因为我很穷，不是富人——他们信任我。他们说，好的。如果你这么说，我们会去多了解关于大屠杀的事情。
By the time he was done, Nasser translated several days of Israel's annual commemoration of the Holocaust. Rest assured this doesn't happen on any other Arabic language station.
当他做完时，纳赛尔翻译了以色列为期几天的年度大屠杀纪念活动。请放心，这不会在任何其他阿拉伯语电台发生。
I spent a day interviewing people around Bethlehem about what they think of the show.
我在伯利恒周围花了一天时间采访人们，看他们对这个节目的看法。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
It's excellent. He's a good journalist. It's fantastic.
太棒了。他是个好记者。太精彩了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
It's very good, because they give us the opinion of the people who are in Israel.
非常好，因为他们给了我们住在以色列的人们的观点。
Almost everyone I talk to watches the program and loves it. People say they do get information there that they can't get anywhere else. One man told me that when the second intifada started, the only way you could find out which Palestinians were wanted by the Israelis and why was by watching Nasser's translation of Israeli TV.
几乎所有我交谈过的人都在看这个节目并且很喜欢它。人们说他们确实在那里得到了在别处无法获得的信息。一个人告诉我，当第二次起义开始时，找出哪些巴勒斯坦人是被以色列人通缉的以及原因的唯一方法，就是观看纳赛尔翻译的以色列电视节目。
Did you ever learn something new about Israelis that you never knew before?
你有没有学到过关于以色列人从未知道过的新东西？
Yeah.
是啊。
Like what?
比如什么？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
That there are some writers or journalists that are on our side of the Palestinian problem--
有些作家或记者站在我们巴勒斯坦问题的一边——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
--against their government.
——反对他们自己的政府。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
It's good to know that there are Israelis who are with us.
知道有以色列人站在我们这边很好。
I saw a very poor Israeli family in the program of Nasser. You know, they are very bad economically. More than us. They have maybe bread to eat. This was a new thing for us.
我在纳赛尔的节目中看到了一个非常贫穷的以色列家庭。你知道，他们的经济状况非常糟糕。比我们还要惨。他们可能只有面包吃。这对比我们来说是件新鲜事。
Bethlehem, where the TV station is, is a dusty, broken down, depressing place. Most businesses are dead or on the ropes. No parks, no pools. In the summer, people often have running water only once a week, or even every two weeks. Israeli army vehicles roll through practically every day, sometimes to demolish a house, and the neighbors pull chairs onto their roofs and sit watching the destruction, since most don't have jobs. There are 12 Israeli settlements within 10 miles of Bethlehem, and they're growing.
伯利恒，也就是电视台所在地，是一个尘土飞扬、破败、压抑的地方。大多数生意都死了或岌岌可危。没有公园，没有游泳池。夏天，人们通常一周只有一次自来水，甚至每两周才有一次。以色列军队的车辆几乎每天都会经过，有时是为了拆毁房屋，邻居们会把椅子拉到屋顶上坐着观看破坏过程，因为大多数人没有工作。伯利恒10英里范围内有12个以色列定居点，而且它们还在增长。
Nasser told me that when he was at work one day, he looked up at the television and saw his own kids, his 11 year old twins, on TV, throwing stones at Israeli tanks and soldiers. He was alarmed. Kids have been shot and killed throwing stones.
纳赛尔告诉我，有天他在工作时，抬头看电视，看到了他自己的孩子，他11岁的双胞胎，在电视上向以色列坦克和士兵扔石头。他很惊慌。孩子因为扔石头被射杀过。
He talked to them about it that night. "Why are you throwing stones?" he said. "Because they're the enemy," they told him. "Who told you that?" he asked. "The kids at school," they said.
那天晚上他跟他们谈了。“你们为什么要扔石头？”他说。“因为他们是敌人，”他们告诉他。“谁告诉你们的？”他问。“学校里的孩子，”他们说。
I asked him if he told them to stop throwing stones, and he said of course. Three, four, five times he told them. And then they started lying and saying they hadn't thrown stones when he knew they had. He doesn't know what to do. When he talks to friends, Israeli journalists, on the phone at home, his 11 year old daughter Beirut says, "I heard you talking Hebrew. Don't talk to those people."
我问他是否告诉他们停止扔石头，他说当然。三、四、五次他告诉他们。然后他们开始撒谎，说他们没扔石头，尽管他知道他们扔了。他不知道该怎么办。当他在家里给朋友、以色列记者打电话时，他11岁的女儿贝鲁特说：“我听到你在讲希伯来语。别跟那些人讲话。”
Nasser has been trying to teach his kids Hebrew, so I interviewed the four of them. None of the kids see learning Hebrew as a bridge to peace the way their dad does. For them it's way more utilitarian. It helps you talk to soldiers, they say. Maybe it can get you out of a bad situation.
纳赛尔一直试图教他的孩子希伯来语，所以我采访了他们四个。没有一个孩子像他们的父亲那样将学习希伯来语视为通向和平的桥梁。对他们来说，这更具实用性。他们说，这有助于你和士兵交谈。也许这能让你脱离危险的处境。
What words and phrases do you know in Hebrew?
你们懂哪些希伯来语单词和短语？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
[SPEAKING ARABIC AND HEBREW]
[阿拉伯语和希伯来语发言]
[SPEAKING HEBREW] in Hebrew, which is in Arabic [SPEAKING ARABIC], which is soldier. [SPEAKING HEBREW]. Good morning. Please, which is [SPEAKING HEBREW]. [SPEAKING HEBREW], OK. [SPEAKING HEBREW], come here. [SPEAKING HEBREW], dumb. And the baby, [SPEAKING HEBREW].
希伯来语的[希伯来语]，即阿拉伯语的[阿拉伯语]，意思是士兵。[希伯来语]。早上好。请，也就是[希伯来语]。[希伯来语]，好的。[希伯来语]，过来。[希伯来语]，笨蛋。还有婴儿，[希伯来语]。
Why do they know the word for dumb?
为什么他们知道“笨蛋”这个词？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Beirut's twin brother Marcel, a tiny boy with a large retainer in his mouth, jumps in.
贝鲁特的孪生兄弟马塞尔，一个嘴里带着大牙套的小个子男孩，插话道。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
The soldiers are saying this to the kids, and the kids are saying this to the soldiers.
士兵们对孩子说这个词，孩子们也对士兵说这个词。
When I talked to your kids yesterday, they definitely said that the reason that they wanted to know Hebrew was to know the language of the enemy, and--
昨天我和你的孩子交谈时，他们明确表示他们想学希伯来语的原因是为了掌握敌人的语言，而且——
Yeah, that's right.
是啊，那是对的。
Does it worry you that your kids aren't getting to meet Israelis at all, and that for them, it is the language of enemy?
你担不担心你的孩子根本见不到以色列人，而且对他们来说，这就是敌人的语言？
Of course I am worried. I'm very worried. I'm worried also because they are throwing stones against the Israeli tanks. I'm worried I don't want them to do that. You can imagine. You are sitting in your office writing and worry about them. What if the soldiers shooted them? What can I say? What can I do? How can I live? What can I say to the others if one of them has been killed?
我当然担心。我非常担心。我也很担心，因为他们正向以色列坦克扔石头。我很担心，我不希望他们那样做。你可以想象。你坐在办公室里写作，却担心着他们。如果士兵射击他们怎么办？我能说什么？我能做什么？我该怎么活下去？如果他们其中一个被杀，我能对别人说什么？
They're not just the tanks, the soldiers who are shooting. Why they are not in the same schools? Why? Why they are not in the same pool to swim? My kids don't know the Israeli people. They don't know the kids in Israel. Someone stop that.
开枪的不只是坦克，还有士兵。为什么他们不在同一所学校上学？为什么？为什么他们不能在同一个游泳池里游泳？我的孩子不认识以色列人。他们不认识以色列的孩子。有人停止这一切吧。
He takes a drag of his cigarette and smiles.
他吸了一口烟，微笑着。
Maybe you can. Try.
也许你能做到。试试吧。
Nasser speaks Hebrew and he's teaching his kids, but actual Israelis are a world away, and he can't convince his own children, a genuine captive audience, not to hate them.
纳赛尔会讲希伯来语，他也在教他的孩子，但真正的以色列人远在天边，他无法说服他自己的孩子——这一真正的囚徒听众——不去恨他们。
Nancy Updike in Jerusalem.
南希·厄普代克，耶路撒冷报道。
Coming up. Start a show in a karaoke bar, end a show in a karaoke bar. No matter how little it has to do with the last story and the last act, can we do it? Dare we do it? Answer is in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public International when our program continues.
接下来。在卡拉OK酒吧开始节目，在卡拉OK酒吧结束节目。无论它与上一个故事和上一幕有多么微小的联系，我们能做到吗？我们敢做到吗？答案将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共电台的节目继续播出后的一分钟内揭晓。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Lost in Translation. We've arrived at Act Three of our show.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“迷失翻译”。我们已经进入节目的第三幕。
Act Three. Translating For the Very, Very, Very, Very, Very, Very Tall.
第三幕，为极其、极其、极其、极其、极其高大的人做翻译。
Well friends, we've heard about the struggles between Palestinians and Israelis, between Russians and Americans. In this act, we ask the age old question, can there ever be peace between the tall and the short? Can people of different heights ever hope to get along? Jesse Hardman tackled the issue.
好了朋友们，我们已经听过了巴勒斯坦人和以色列人、俄罗斯人和美国人之间的斗争。在这一幕中，我们要问一个古老的问题：高个子和矮个子之间能有和平吗？不同身高的人能希望相处融洽吗？杰西·哈德曼解决了这个问题。
My earliest memory of my cousin Colin is fighting with him over a Fernando Valenzuela baseball card. We were both seven years old, both way into sports and pretty competitive. Mainly we'd play basketball. If you ask me, I'm a little bit better than he is. Don't ask him.
我关于表弟科林最早的记忆是和他争夺一张费尔南多·瓦伦苏埃拉的棒球卡。我们当时都七岁，都非常喜欢运动，而且竞争心很强。我们主要玩篮球。如果你问我，我会说我比他强一点。别去问他。
After graduating from college, Colin headed straight to Taiwan and stayed there for almost three years, just knocking around, trying to figure out what he wanted to do with this life. He took classes, worked a few jobs. He also played a lot of basketball with locals at nearby gyms. This left him with a very specialized, but seemingly a marketable vocabulary.
大学毕业后，科林直接去了台湾，在那里待了近三年，到处游荡，试图弄明白自己这辈子想干什么。他上过课，做过几份工作。他还经常和当地人在附近的健身房打篮球。这让他掌握了一套非常专业，但看起来很有市场的词汇。
Slam dunk?
灌篮？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文发言]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文发言]
Weak side defense?
弱侧防守？
In Chinese, I just say the side without the ball.
用中文，我只是说没有球的那一边。
When I caught up with Colin two summers ago, he was working for the US government in a dead end job, translating Chinese documents. He was determined to start being practical. The words "law school" forced their way out of his mouth. You could tell he was hitting the career default button. Then an old friend stepped in.
两年前夏天我见到科林时，他正为美国政府做一份死胡同工作，翻译中文文件。他决心开始变得务实。他嘴里挤出了“法学院”这几个字。你能看出他正在点击职业的默认设置按钮。然后一位老朋友介入了。
And she had this piece of paper with a job description. "NBA player seeks full-time interpreter. Looking for a native English speaker, fluent in mandarin Chinese, interested in basketball." It was like, yeah, right.
她手里拿着一张职位说明书。“NBA球员寻求全职翻译。寻找以英语为母语，精通中文普通话，对篮球感兴趣的人。”就像是，是啊，得了吧。
Two weeks later, my cousin had made the jump from owning baseball cards to working for one. Sort of.
两周后，我的表弟完成了从拥有棒球卡到为棒球卡持有者工作的大跳跃。某种程度上。
Now, FOX 26 Sports with Keith [? Guggans. ?]
现在，福克斯26台体育频道报道，基思·古根斯。
Hi again. Yao Ming in Houston for what, 24 hours or so? The hoopla includes plenty of wide eyes and lots of curiosity seekers, as if they'd never seen a 7'6" Chinese millionaire before.
你好，再次回来。姚明在休斯顿待了大概24小时左右？这阵轰动带来了许多睁大眼睛的好奇者，好像他们从来没见过一个7英尺6英寸的中国百万富翁一样。
It turns out that Colin's new job wasn't with some benchwarming experiment. Yao Ming is the starting center for the Houston Rockets. And if you haven't heard of him, congratulations. You officially know nothing about sports in America. He's the biggest story out of the NBA this year. The first foreigner ever to go number one in the NBA draft. His style of play is supposed to revolutionize the game the same way that Michael Jordan's did. Add to this, he has the hopes and dreams of a billion emerging NBA fans in Asia riding on his shoulders. And Colin met him for the first time the same day the rest of America did.
原来科林的这份新工作并不是什么板凳席上的实验。姚明是休斯顿火箭队的首发中锋。如果你没听说过他，祝贺你。你正式对美国的体育一无所知。他是今年NBA最大的新闻。第一个在NBA选秀中成为状元的外国人。他的打球风格被认为将彻底改变比赛，就像迈克尔·乔丹所做的那样。此外，他肩负着亚洲十亿新兴NBA球迷的希望和梦想。科林见到他第一面的那天，正是美国其他人见到他的那天。
Yao Ming.
姚明。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
You know, at the airport at first, there weren't that many people, and all of a sudden, you get this whole lobby. It's just crowded. And the people are surrounding him, and you know, I had to get up and translate right away. He had to give a few brief statements to the crowd. And we had never met.
你知道，在机场起初，并没有那么多人，然后突然之间，你就得到了整个大厅。全是挤满的人。人们围着他，你知道，我必须马上站起来翻译。他必须对人群发表几句简短的声明。我们之前从没见过面。
Speaking through interpreter Colin Pine, Ming says he's anxious to get on the court and work on his game with his new teammates.
通过翻译科林·派恩，明说他渴望进入球场，和新队友磨练他的比赛技术。
After waiting such a long time, it's like opening a door and having a breath of fresh air.
在等待了这么久之后，就像打开了一扇门，呼吸到新鲜空气一样。
I think my heart was about to burst through my chest. And I'm up there with the lights on me, with Yao Ming sitting next to me, and then-- I've heard of instances of people who had to do translation in situations like that just choking. Just not being able to say anything. I'm floating above the ceiling, looking back at myself doing this. Just for me to get through the first time, I was pretty happy.
我想我的心脏快要从胸腔里跳出来了。我站在那儿，灯光照着我，姚明就坐在我旁边，然后——我听过在那种情况下做翻译的人因为窒息而说不出话的例子。就好像什么也说不出来。我浮在天花板上方，看着自己在那儿做这件事。仅仅能完成第一次，我就很开心了。
Fans, it's time to stand up, make some noise, and get ready to meet your Minnesota Timberwolves.
球迷们，是时候站起来，制造点动静，准备迎接你们的明尼苏达森林狼队了。
Early in the season, I catch up with Colin at a game in Minnesota. My first chance to see his new life from the inside.
赛季初期，我在明尼苏达的一场比赛中见到科林。我第一次有机会从内部看看他的新生活。
Yeah, you're right here.
是啊，你就在这儿。
We stand in a nondescript concrete hallway near the visiting locker room. Players are walking by, ribbing Colin and smacking him on the ass. Superstars like Glen Rice and Steve Francis, Colin's idol since college. Guys I'm used to seeing on TV.
我们站在客队更衣室附近一条不起眼的混凝土走廊里。球员们走过，打趣科林，拍打他的屁股。像格伦·莱斯和史蒂夫·弗朗西斯这样的超级巨星，那是科林从大学以来的偶像。那些我习惯在电视上看到的人。
Colin disappears into the Rockets' locker room. A few minutes later, he reappears with his new boss, Yao Ming.
科林消失在火箭队的更衣室里。几分钟后，他又带着他的新老板姚明出现了。
Yao is 7'5". Colin's my height, 5'9" in shoes. Yao slouches up against the locker room wall. Colin leans in next to him. A crush of TV cameras, microphones, and notepads descend on the pair. Lots of the reporters are from Asia.
姚身高7英尺5英寸。科林和我一样高，穿鞋5英尺9英寸。姚靠在更衣室的墙上。科林在他旁边弯下腰。一堆电视摄像机、麦克风和笔记本降临在两人身上。很多记者来自亚洲。
Wait! Excuse me. Hey, wait, wait, wait! Excuse me. Let me translate, please. Thank you.
等等！不好意思。嘿，等等，等等，等等！不好意思。让我翻译一下，拜托。谢谢。
It's a month into the season, and media fascination with Yao's story is bigger than anyone imagined. Yao is the only player who reporters want to talk to before and after every game, regardless of how he plays.
赛季进行了一个月，媒体对姚明故事的迷恋程度超过了所有人的想象。无论姚明打得如何，他是记者在每场比赛前后唯一想谈论的球员。
The questions tend to be the same in every city. Questions about adapting to the NBA and life in America. What do you do in your spare time? Have you sampled the local cuisine? And of course--
在每个城市，问题倾向于一样。关于适应NBA和美国生活的问题。业余时间你做什么？你品尝过当地菜肴吗？当然还有——
Does he see himself as a role model to other Asians in America?
他是否认为自己是美国其他亚裔的榜样？
For the most part, Yao feeds them straight sports cliche. One day at a time. I'm still learning the game. But every once in a while, he'll give them an answer that leaves reporters scratching their heads. Like this question, when the reporter asks, what's it like to play against Minnesota star Kevin Garnett?
在很大程度上，姚明给他们的都是直接的体育陈词滥调。一天一天来。我还在学习比赛。但偶尔，他会给他们一个让记者抓耳挠腮的答案。就像这个问题，当记者问，和明尼苏达球星凯文·加内特对决是什么感觉？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文发言]
He seems like a spider, [INAUDIBLE]
他看起来像个蜘蛛，[听不清]
Spider?
蜘蛛？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文发言]
He's got strong arms and strong legs. Spider. [SPEAKING CHINESE] Yeah, like a spider.
他有强壮的手臂和强壮的腿。蜘蛛。[中文发言] 是的，就像蜘蛛。
The bulk of Colin's translating work is just getting Yao through these daily press conferences. Yao speaks enough English to communicate with coaches and players during games and practices, but Colin sits with the team courtside, just in case.
科林大部分的翻译工作只是帮助姚明完成这些日常新闻发布会。姚明说的英语足够在比赛和练习中与教练和队友交流，但科林坐在球队场边，以防万一。
You sit right there, behind the bench and the red seats like that?
你就坐在那里，在那块替补席后面的红座位上吗？
They don't need me that much.
他们不需要我那么多。
So what do you do most of the game?
那你大部分时间都在做什么？
Watch and cheer and try not to say too much. I've got to be careful. I'm a very enthusiastic fan. But I need to maintain a professional demeanor, I suppose.
观看、欢呼，尽量少说话。我必须小心。我是一个非常热情的球迷。但我得保持职业风度，我想。
Fast forward two hours. Fourth quarter. Rockets down by six with a few minutes to go.
快进两小时。第四节。比赛还剩几分钟，火箭队落后六分。
Oh, come on!
哦，拜托！
So much for professional demeanor.
职业风度就此终结。
Argh!
啊！
Colin's up out of his seat, looking like he wants a piece of the ref. But if anything, this actually helps him fit in with the team. Here's backup center Kelvin Cato and backup point guard Richie Norris.
科林从座位上跳起来，看起来想上去找裁判理论。但如果有的话，这反而帮助他融入了球队。这是替补中锋凯尔文·卡托和替补控卫里奇·诺里斯。
And it's not just the players who glow about Colin. A Rockets executive tells me that most NBA translators are just linguists with no feeling for the game, but Colin's made it way easier for Yao.
不仅仅是球员对科林赞不绝口。一位火箭队高管告诉我，大多数NBA翻译只是没有比赛感觉的语言学家，但科林让姚明的生活变得轻松多了。
Even the press loves him. Sam Smith is a veteran basketball beat writer for the Chicago Sun-Times.
连媒体也喜欢他。萨姆·史密斯是芝加哥太阳时报的一位资深篮球记者。
Yeah. We're going to go to Burger King right now. Right.
是啊。我们要去汉堡王了。好的。
Where's his dad?
他爸爸在哪儿？
I don't know.  Here, talk to Yao Ming. I'm going crazy here.
我不知道。嘿，去跟姚明谈谈。我要疯了。
Here's what most of my cousin's glamorous job looks like up close. Usually he and Yao are nowhere near a basketball court. Usually he's not even translating. Right here, Colin is trying to get Yao to the DMV so he can take his driver's test. It's part of Colin's job to be Yao's driving instructor.
这是我表弟那份光鲜工作的近距离视角。通常他和姚明离篮球场十万八千里。通常他甚至根本没在翻译。就在这儿，科林正试图带姚明去机动车管理局参加驾照考试。这是科林的工作之一，当姚明的驾驶教练。
The problem today is, a National Geographic film crew wants to tag along. Colin can't find Yao's dad, who's also taking the test, and Yao is hungry. Colin literally can't go 10 minutes without having his cell phone ring, and it's never for him. Yao's agents, people from the Rockets, from the press, from the companies Yao endorses, even Yao's parents-- they all get to him through Colin.
今天的问题是，国家地理的摄制组想跟着一起去。科林找不到姚明的父亲，他也要参加考试，而且姚明饿了。科林简直每10分钟手机就会响，而且从来不是打给他的。姚明的经纪人、火箭队的人、媒体、姚明代言公司的代表，甚至姚明的父母——他们都通过科林联系姚明。
Hey Angie, it's Colin. I just wanted to find, when is a good time? When am I going to be able to give you this stuff? After the game, or? Like, the tea, and I have something I need to give you, and I think I have a check from Yao Ming or his mother--
嘿安吉，我是科林。我只是想找一下，什么时候比较方便？我什么时候能把这些东西给你？比赛结束后，还是？就像，茶，我有些东西需要给你，我觉得我有一张来自姚明或者他妈妈的支票——
Here's something else. Colin lives with Yao in a huge house, in a gated community, in a Houston suburb, together with Yao's mother and father, who keep a tight leash on their 22 year old son. Originally, Colin was supposed have his own place, but the Yaos invited him into the house early in the season. He thought about it and decided it made sense, since he'd be spending almost every minute with Yao anyway.
还有一件事。科林和姚明住在一起，在休斯顿郊区一个有门禁的社区里的一栋大房子里，和姚明的母亲、父亲住在一起，他们对他们22岁的儿子管得很严。最初，科林应该有自己的住处，但姚家人在赛季初邀请他住进房子里。他考虑了一下，觉得这也说得通，反正他几乎每分钟都要和姚明待在一起。
It also felt like, you know, they were being very nice in offering, and I thought I didn't want to offend them by turning them down. But it made sense. It just made a lot of sense.
这也觉得像是，你知道，他们提供得很客气，我觉得拒绝他们会冒犯他们。但这说得通。真的很说得通。
But I mean, I'm 29, and I'm not accustomed to living with a family. Sometimes I think that his mom looks at me as a little kid. I know she worries if I don't eat enough, or you know. And it's really sweet. It's nice. But it's a little strange.
但我是说，我29岁了，我不习惯和家庭生活在一起。有时我觉得他妈妈把我当成个小孩子。我知道如果我不吃够，她会担心的，或者你知道。这真的很贴心。很好。但有点奇怪。
It'd be strange to move back in with your own family at 29, let alone a Chinese family you just met, which doesn't speak English, and whose shortest member, Yao's mom, is a half foot taller than you.
29岁搬回去和自己的家庭住已经够奇怪了，更别说住进一个你刚认识、不会说英语、而且最矮的成员（姚妈妈）都比你高半英尺的中国家庭。
Colin doesn't like talking about his home life with the Yaos. That's private. So private that he never has anyone over to visit, friends or family. He can't even invite me in for a beer.
科林不喜欢谈论他和姚一家的家庭生活。那是隐私。隐私到他从不带任何人回家做客，朋友或家人都不行。他甚至不能邀请我进去喝杯啤酒。
No, no, no, no, no, no no, no, no, no.
不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。
Two days after Yao passes his driving test, I tag along with him and Colin as they head home from practice. They sing along to the radio together. They finish each other's sentences and tease each other in a mixture of English and Chinese.
姚明通过驾照考试两天后，我在他们练习回家路上跟着他和科林。他们一起跟着收音机唱歌。他们替对方补全句子，用英语和中文的混合语互相调侃。
You know, before I met him, I think Colin is maybe 40 years old people. When I saw them, I think, oh, my God. It's a young boy. Maybe younger than me. But I ask him, he say 28. I said, 28? He looks very young!
你知道，我遇见他之前，我想科林大概是40岁左右。当我见到他们时，我想，天啊。是个小男孩。可能比我还小。但我问他，他说28岁。我说，28？他看起来太年轻了！
Does Colin have any annoying traits? Does he not clean up his room anything? Does he hog the Nintendo?
科林有什么讨人厌的习惯吗？他有什么不收拾房间之类的事吗？他会霸占任天堂吗？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文发言]
He can't beat me, so I'm the one who's always hogging it.
他赢不了我，所以我才是那个一直霸占着玩的人。
Their bond has been formed through an intense mutual experience. The world of the NBA is foreign to both of them.
他们的纽带是通过一种紧张的共同体验形成的。NBA的世界对他们两人来说都很陌生。
There were lots of times, especially on the road, you know, we'd have dinner in a hotel room, and we'd talk. And we'd say-- I would get stressed out over a press conference or something, and I'd tell him, you know, this is why I'm stressed. And he'd do his best to help me after that.
有很多次，特别是在客场，你知道，我们在酒店房间吃饭，聊天。我们说——我会因为新闻发布会之类的事感到压力很大，我会告诉他，你知道，这就是我感到压力的原因。之后他会尽力帮助我。
And it was harder for me to help him, because you know, the pressure on him was so much greater. I mean, for instance, was it the second Laker game in LA? We lost in overtime, and he fouled out. And he was really upset. And I did my-- I said, if you hadn't-- he had a great game, though. And I said, if you hadn't played well, we probably wouldn't have gotten here. Gone into overtime.
而且要我帮他更难，因为你知道，他身上的压力要大得多。我是说，比如，那是洛杉矶的第二场湖人比赛吗？我们在加时赛输了，他犯满离场。他非常沮丧。我做了我的——我说，如果你没——不过他打得很好。我说，如果你没打得那么好，我们可能根本到不了这儿。进不了加时赛。
The only thing I can do is just be an ear. Be somebody, you know, who says, I understand. And then mean it. Because I got to see it firsthand.
我唯一能做的就是倾听。做一个，你知道，能说“我理解”的人。而且是真心的。因为我亲眼见证了这一切。
Three fourths of the way through the basketball season, I catch a Rockets game at Madison Square Garden in New York City. It's a packed house, despite the fact the New York team, the Knicks, suck.
篮球赛季进入四分之三时，我在纽约麦迪逊广场花园看了场火箭队的比赛。座无虚席，尽管纽约队——尼克斯队，很烂。
Almost a third of the crowd is Chinese, many of them attending their first NBA game. They're here because of Yao, who's now a full-fledged phenomenon. He's only been in the US for four months, but he's already the new face of Apple Computer, Gatorade, and Visa.
观众中近三分之一是华人，其中很多人是第一次看NBA比赛。他们是因为姚明才来到这儿的，他现在是一个名副其实的现象级球星。他到美国才四个月，但已经是苹果电脑、佳得乐和Visa的新面孔了。
To the surprise of the normal Knicks crowd, Yao's army comes ready to scream, and many have made homemade signs proclaiming their love of Yao.
让普通尼克斯球迷惊讶的是，姚之队随时准备尖叫，许多人制作了宣称热爱姚明的自制标语。
What's your sign say here?
你这标语上写着什么？
Yao Ming, The Next Big Thing.
姚明，下一个大人物。
What's so exciting about him?
他有什么那么令人兴奋的？
Honestly, I feel very proud. I plan on opening a basketball camp in Pakistan in the future because of this. And I want to, like, open the doors for Pakistanis to get into the game of basketball.
老实说，我感到很骄傲。因为这个，我计划在将来在巴基斯坦开一家篮球训练营。我想，为巴基斯坦人打开进入篮球比赛的大门。
That's right. Pakistan. This is the power of Yao Ming. He's united the Asian mainland with the Indian subcontinent.
没错。巴基斯坦。这就是姚明的力量。他联合了亚洲大陆和印度次大陆。
Just to see how far his celebrity extends, I ask this 22 year old fan about my cousin.
为了看看他的名声延伸到什么程度，我问了这个22岁的球迷关于我表弟的问题。
He's got a translator. What do you think of that job?
他有个翻译。你觉得那份工作怎么样？
Well, I actually have a sign for him right there.
嗯，我其实在那儿有个标语是给他的。
What does it say?
写着什么？
Right here. "Move over Batman and Robin. We have some new heroes in town, Yao Ming and Colin Pine. Citizens of Houston have no fear. Ming and Pine are here."
就在这儿。“闪开蝙蝠侠和罗宾。我们城里有了新英雄，姚明和科林·派恩。休斯顿市民不必担心。明和派恩在这儿。”
I'm just a huge fan. Colin Pine-- he's Yao's right hand man right now. I mean, he's the one that's doing all the talking for Yao in English. So we get Yao's word through him.
我只是个大粉丝。科林·派恩——他现在是姚明的得力助手。我是说，他是在用英语替姚明说话的人。所以我们通过他得到了姚明的话。
Is he a celebrity?
他是名人吗？
Oh, definitely. When you're anyone around Yao, it's a celebrity. I'll tell you that much.
哦，绝对是。当你和姚明在一起时，你就是名人。我只能告诉你这么多。
I'm floored by this. And my question of the night becomes, who's Colin Pine?
我被惊呆了。而我晚上的问题变成了，谁是科林·派恩？
You guys know who Colin Pine is?
你们知道科林·派恩是谁吗？
The interpreter.
那个翻译。
Yao Ming's translator.
姚明的翻译。
We actually ran into Colin Pine in Chinatown in Houston at a tiny karaoke bar. Colin Pine was singing perfect Mandarin.
我们其实在休斯顿中国城的一家小卡拉OK酒吧遇到了科林·派恩。科林·派恩在唱完美的普通话歌曲。
One woman knows so much about him, that she could have written this story.
一个女人对他了解得如此之多，她甚至能写出这个故事。
Well, he worked in the State Department, and he applied online and didn't think he would get the job, and was shocked when they called, and basically he was told he had to be here like yesterday. And he was excited because he was a huge Steve Francis fan.
嗯，他在国务院工作，在网上申请了，没想过会得到这份工作，当他们打电话时他很震惊，基本上有人告诉他他必须像昨天一样到这儿。他很兴奋，因为他曾是史蒂夫·弗朗西斯的超级粉丝。
Before I think he was translating documents with the US government. He must be the luckiest man in the world right now.
之前我觉得他在用美国政府翻译文件。他现在一定是世界上最幸运的人。
That guy's got the best job in the world.
那家伙拥有一份世界上最好的工作。
I'd like to have his job.
我想拥有他的工作。
In my very informal survey, 50% of the crowd knows my cousin my name. One Chinese-American coed who carries a sign saying, "I'm single and bilingual-- hey Yao, you and me, let's mingle" tells me my cousin's hot. Colin's heard it before.
在我非常非正式的调查中，50%的观众能叫出我表弟的名字。一个带着标语说“我单身且会双语——嘿姚，你和我，让我们交往吧”的华裔美国女大学生说我表弟很火。科林以前听说过。
I've had girls pass me cards. Not often. It's not like-- the players get it all the time, I'm sure. But consciously and subconsciously, there's part of me that is really wary of the whole thing. You know, I want somebody to like me for the witty, intelligent, charming person that I am.
我有过女孩子递给我卡片。不多。不像——球员总是收到，我肯定。但有意识或潜意识里，我心里有一部分确实对整件事非常谨慎。你知道，我想要某人是因为我是一个风趣、聪明、有魅力的人而喜欢我。
My friends are like, this job is so wasted on you.
我的朋友们说，这份工作对你来说太浪费了。
You're up.
轮到你了。
Oh, it's me again.
哦，又是由于我。
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
[中文演唱]
On a warm spring night, Yao, Colin, and I are out at a Chinese karaoke bar. Yao just passed his driving exam and he wants to celebrate. He never goes out. This is a really big deal. He's out of the house and his parents aren't around.
在一个温暖的春夜，姚、科林和我正待在中国城的一家卡拉OK酒吧。姚刚通过驾驶考试，他想庆祝一下。他从不出去。这真是一件大事。他离开了家，他父母不在身边。
The club sits in a stucco Chinese mini mall in a cookie cutter Houston suburb between a nail salon and a takeout place called The Fancy Noodle. Everyone has a couple of beers, but this is definitely the G-rated version of an NBA night out.
这家俱乐部坐落于休斯顿郊区一个灰泥粉刷的中国小型购物中心里，在一家美甲店和一家叫“精致面馆”的外卖店之间。每个人都喝了几杯啤酒，但这绝对是NBA夜生活G级版本。
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
[中文演唱]
Colin loves karaoke. He sings a Chinese love ballad with an English chorus-- "I Only Want To Be Your Friend." Yao, appropriately enough, responds with the Backstreet Boys hit, "Larger Than Life."
科林喜欢卡拉OK。他唱了一首带有英语副歌的中文情歌——“我只想做你的朋友”。姚明，非常恰当地，用后街男孩的畅销曲“超乎人生”回应。
[SINGING]
[演唱]
Yao later tells me this night was the most fun he's had in America.
姚后来告诉我，这个夜晚是他来美国后玩得最开心的时刻。
Five years from now you're going to be veteran in the league. You'll be superstar. And you'll speak English, and you won't need an interpreter. So who will Colin Pine be to you then, in five years?
五年后你将成为联赛中的老将。你会是超级巨星。你会说英语，不需要翻译。那么五年后，科林·派恩对你来说是谁？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文发言]
Still friends.
还是朋友。
Still friends. Do you think you'll hang out still?
还是朋友。你觉得你们还会常一起玩吗？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文发言]
If you don't mind, and you don't mind me stealing your girlfriend, then it's OK.
如果你不介意，你也不介意我偷走你的女朋友的话，那就没问题。
Jesse Hartman.
杰西·哈特曼。
You know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times , all at audible.com.
你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们的节目音频，在那里他们有公共广播节目、畅销书籍，甚至是《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Nancy Updike's story was part of the Hearing Voices project, which gets funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting and is online at hearingvoices.com.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。南希·厄普代克的故事是“倾听声音”项目的一部分，该项目从公共广播公司获得资金，并在hearingvoices.com上在线发布。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Torey Malatia, who calls me up drunk at least once a week and says,
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他每周至少打一次醉酒电话给我说，
Hey, how about a little male-bashing?
嘿，来点抨击男人的段子怎么样？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。